it is happy national empanada day
everybody now
woo cheering now if you don't know what
empanadas are we brought in an expert to
show you what you've been missing
okay let's welcome josh molina owner and
ceo of makers
and finders along with executive kenneth
taylor hey guys
hey how's it going hey i am ready to eat
i understand that makers and finers has
an assortment of empanadas to choose
from so let's start
with what we got yeah yeah we have
11 different empanadas including vegan
ones as well we're going to go ahead and
start with the black bean empanada okay
chef ken's going to go ahead and grab a
scoop of black beans
put it in one of your empanada discs
okay
now i'm doing this along with you guys
by the way yeah for sure come on
okay we've got the black beans and then
if you i don't think you have a fork
there so what we're going to do is we're
going to use our fingertips to close
right okay you're going to
you're going to seal the empanada and
chef's going to show you how do it in me
okay so i'm not much of a
worried wait okay i should probably take
the plastic off of the open
should probably do that okay all right
i'm listening
all right so you're just going to kind
of fold it and close the ends okay
now what's the technique here what's the
secret so you're going to use your thumb
to press
one end up to the other end of the
empanada okay and then one
finger to fold it over and then follow
that fold with your thumb
and then just kind of press guys i'm
really less than impressed with my work
here
i'm trying it's not sticking so how do
you make it stick
you do you have a little bit of water on
you did they set it up for you oh
no i don't have a little bit see that's
that's what's happening
i i might just run i'm gonna grab some
water just to try and see
if this helps if this helps
okay so as we're as i'm trying to do
this let's talk more about the different
kinds of empanadas you guys have
at the restaurant for sure we have uh
four different vegan empanadas and we
have eight different fillings of
empiranas everything from
chicken tinga short rib
garlic shrimp and for the vegans we have
a soyrizo and peppers
it comes with a lemon wedge also a uh
black bean which is the one that you're
trying to make right now guys wait a
minute okay that sounds great but i'm
i'm i think i'm getting it can we get a
closer look
the water really helped the water really
helped
how'd i do i got you gotta ignore the
black beans in my nails but i'm sure you
guys are used to that
okay let's talk happy hour specials
because i hear you can get some
empanadas for some good prices too
yeah once a week every wednesday all
empanadas are two dollars
so you can come in order up to three per
person
um and then also during happy hour four
to six pm monday through saturday
they're three dollars per empanada a la
carte
ooh that is a great deal and such a good
treat okay let's talk about the finished
product now
i'm picking this up so you could either
deep fry it it takes about six to seven
minutes in a deep fryer 350 degrees
or you can do it in a in an oven 500
degrees for about 15 minutes
oh you see that
delicious okay as i take a bite now let
us know about the new spring menu
because i hear it's fire
yeah chef ken and the culinary team
makers and finders have been putting
together
an incredible new menu we have latin
honey toast
benedict's we have input breakfast
empanada skillets now morning power
skillets
egg whites spanish rice beans
and avocado a delicious menu a healthy
menu and a lot of new vegan options as
well
all right i love it and i will go ahead
and make my reservation thank you guys
we'll see you soon see you later for
more information head to makerslv.com
ken dawson over to you
you are an empanada i know you want
something you i am going to have
something you did a good job with that
thank you
the water helped yeah all right